hi guys so this past week I got to take
a tour of Mattel and check out how they
make their new video girl Barbie doll
it's kind of amazing because she has a
video camera in her necklace and an LCD
screen on her back and she even comes
with video editing software you can
record it's 25 minutes of video then you
can just plug her directly into your
computer using you must be forward and
start editing where were these things
when I was growing up I'm so jealous I
wanted to share with you guys a few of
the clips from my tour and yeah let me
know what you guys think some of you
guys have ever wondered how they
actually put the hair into Barbie dolls
well we're here at the hair routing and
Hair Design Station and she's gonna show
us exactly how they do that a tiny
little needle pulls the hair inside of
the doll's head and creates a lock and
stitch to keep her hair from falling out
when you brush it I'm only doing my hair
in the morning was that simple
so cool video girls hairstyle was chosen
as an updo so that you'd be able to see
the LCD screen she's also wearing a
hoodie so you can hide the screen when
you're not using it now the little fun
fact Barbie's hair is made from the same
company that makes saran wrap so there
she is from a piece of plastic to a
beautiful Barbie doll so this was the
first prototype it had a webcam before
specifically webcam me sighs Wow Kim
sighs yeah and then and then two
prototypes like that this is the string
bag cover body up in booth yeah missiles
in there which your hair still looks
good I mean that's important so here's a
bunch of the dolls and see the entire
process that they went to get the actual
final alright guys so I'm going to edit
my first Barbie movie in the Barbie
editing software this is pretty amazing
because it has all of the tools that
you're going to need to do to edit
yourself a movie okay there's some clips
here I didn't so simple you just drop
the clips right in and there's some
Barbies and add a transition here you're
watching my next bar will hit here on
YouTube it's going to be the best video
I've ever made my life ready
voila I worked really hard on this you
had like it's good so I had an awesome
time at Barbie and it's kind of crazy
because honestly you never realize how
much time and detail something like this
takes to create I also got this awesome
Barbie bag and I had a little flashback
because when I was younger this was my
favorite Barbie doll
it was the astronaut I had that one
right there as you guys know I always
wanted to be an astronaut the question
for you guys those of you that grew up
with Barbies which ones did you have and
which career was your favorite and what
do you think of the new video girl
Barbie doll I mean honestly it's enough
coolest thing ever oh and that's not the
best part she comes with a pink USB cord
is that not amazing the would love it
there you are so that's recording right
now drop my microphone